you're a psychopath in this movie yes
but only in the movie
no i'm a good liar i'm a born liar
i was going to say if you like me you'll
like the movie
if you don't like me you like it it's
kind of like this love-hate
thing the movie's called fear do you
have a
affair what's your big fair i have
plenty of fears
which i don't want to share not one
i got all the time in the world this
movie is also about a 16 year old girl
she ends up with a broken heart because
you're not quite what she thought you
were
yeah this is where you actually first
meet reese witherspoon yes
you were playing pool yeah the first
time i actually
laid my stalking eyes on her you're kind
of two people
because i mentioned before he's very
leaving to beaver and then he turns into
a grown up chucky
yeah but yeah then you got a problem on
your hands
i was pretty much excited to play the
part you know until i realized you know
i get along with everybody that i'm
supposed to be trying to kill
you know so it's not everything i
thought it was
what do you mean well i don't want to
give away the ending of the movie
right you know like the ending comes
back to haunt me some pretty bad stuff
happens
yeah do you want to get away from the
image of the calvin klein
underwear hunky guy
the sex symbol yo calvin klein is
definitely in the house he knows that
that's my man is that something that you
do you
like it you know i don't i don't get
bothered by it too much
you know whether it's marky mark or
formerly known as marky mark you know
the rapper turned underwear mom
whatever that's cool i never really
thought i would have an opportunity
unless i you know
bent over backwards to show people that
i was able to do it that i could be in a
smart movie
you know and actually you know play a
role that was totally different from who
i am in real life and who i
have you know been perceived as in
throughout my career
so that was great
you know i don't really know anybody
who's like that you know
i just kind of got it in my mind that i
needed to have that and i needed to do
anything
possible to get it i know where the
gazillion young animals
who want to go out there and and play
you know
the psycho type of character you know
the taxi driver
this type of guy you know and i got the
opportunity
you know i don't want to do it all the
time and you do bad guys well
well thank you but you got to see i play
a hell of a good guy
in my next movie you feel bad for me
even that's hard to believe
how could you feel bad for me i think
the angels
have blessed us all because of you
oh i'm a good liar i'm a boring liar
practice i kind of put on a sad face
tell mom it wasn't me
where's the big difference for you as
far as acting and
singing or ah
well you kind of music performing live
is
is something totally different but i've
actually you know since i've acted and
then
been on stage i've actually been able to
incorporate a lot of things that i
learned you know
on sets of movies and from actors and
from acting
into my show
come on okay why she always watches e.t
oh god
yeah we like that you know
everybody watches et et is the best show
on television
e.t all those other shows copy shows
clone shows they're no good don't watch
them
wouldn't say it if i didn't mean it
there you go
[Music]